TONIGHT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
STATISTIC THAT'S COME UP.
IT'S VERY WORRISOME. ACCORDING
TO ONE POLL,
58% OF AMERICANS NOW THINK
THERE'S A
WAR ON POLICE.
NOW LOOK I'VE TALKED ABOUT WHAT
I SAW WERE ABUSES BY THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT ON THIS SHOW.
I'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THAT.
I HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT IN MY
FAMILY SO THIS IS VERY
CONCERNING TO ME.
BUT THEN I SAW THIS.
>> 2015 IS TO BE ONE OF THE
LOWEST TOTALS OF OFFICERS GUNNED
DOWN IN THE LINE OF DUTY IN THE
LAST 25 YEARS.
>> OKAY.
WELL YES.
I GUESS IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
REAL TRUTH IS 2015 IS SHAPING TO
BE ONE OF THE SAFEST YEARS FOR
POLICE EVER.
AND NOT MANY THIS DYING IN LOWER
NUMBERS BUT THEY'RE ALSO BEING
ATTACKED LESS.
WELL WAIT A MINUTE, THAT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
SO OVERALL, ATTACK ON POLICE ARE
WAY DOWN YET THE PERCEPTIONS OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OF THE
ATTACKS ON POLICE ARE WAY UP.
OKAY, YOU MAY BE WONDERING HOW
THAT HAPPENS.
THE ANSWER?
MAGIC.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THE MAGICIAN?
FOX NEWS.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, I'M A
MAGICIAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE NIGHTLY SHOW, VERY NICE.
NOW LET'S JUST SAY FOR
DEMONSTRATION PURPOSES I SHOW
YOU ONE CARD, OKAY.
I COVER IT.
THAT CARD IS WHAT, THE KING OF
DIAMONDS, RIGHT.
I JUST LIFT UP MY HAND AND NOW
IT LOOKS DIFFERENT.
NOW NORMALLY YOU'D BE A LITTLE
SUSPICIOUS BUT NOT IF THERE'S
NOTHING TO SEE.
OKAY?
[APPLAUSE]
YES.
NOW HE'S GOOD.
OKAY I'M GOING TO BREAK THE
MAGICIAN'S CODE I'M GOING TO
SHOW YOU HOW TO DO THAT TRICK.
I SHOULDN'T TELL YOU BUT I'M
GOING TO TELL YOU GUYS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
I'M MAGIC.
FOX ON THE OTHER HAND DOESN'T
USE MAGIC, THEY JUST USE GOOD
OLD FASHION TRICKERATION.
HOW DOES FOX TURN SOMETHING THAT
ISN'T INTO SOMETHING THAT IS.
YOU LIKE THAT?
VERY GOOD, VERY GOOD.
OKAY. HERE'S HOW THEY DO IT.
FIRST, STATE YOUR [BLEEP]
PREMISE.
>> SHERIFF MIKE LOUIS SAYS THE
RECENT ATTACKS HIGHLIGHT A TREND
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE UNDER
SIEGE.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN IT LIKE THIS.
THIS IS SCARY SCARY TIME FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THIS COUNTRY IT
TRULY IS.
>> Larry: NOW HE DOESN'T MEAN
SPOOKY SCARY LIKE THE POLICE ARE
DEALING WITH A LOT OF CREAKY
DOORS AND PALE VICTORIAN
CHILDREN HUMMING NURSERY RHYMES.
THEY'RE NOT CREEPED OUT, THEY'RE
SCARED AND THEY'RE SCARED
BECAUSE YOU'RE SCARING THEM, FOX
OKAY. AND THEN YOU TAKE YOUR
[BLEEP] NARRATIVE
TO THE NEXT LEVEL BY TAKING IT
TO FOX'S
HIGHEST HONOR, OFFICIAL WAR
STATUS.
>> NYPD COMMISSIONER
BILL BRATTON PREDICTING DIRE
CONSEQUENCES FROM WHAT HE SEES
AS A WAR ON COPS.
>> THERE IS A WAR ON COPS.
WHAT'S FUELING THIS WAR ON COP.
>> THIS IS A WAR ON COPS.
>> WAR ON POLICE.
THE WAR ON POLICE.
>> ISN'T IT OBVIOUS POLICE HAVE
A BIG TARGET ON THEIR
BACK.
>> Larry: FOX IS GOING ALL IN
ON THIS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN FOX THIS EXCITED
SINCE THE INVENTION OF BLONDE
THAT'S VERY EXCITING, VERY
EXCITING.
OKAY.
BUT NOW HERE'S THE THING.
THE AUDIENCE IS HOOKED.
IN MAGIC WE CALL THAT THE
PRESTIGE -- NO WE DON'T.
THAT MOVIE DIDN'T KNOW [BLEEP]
ABOUT MAGIC
GIVING US A FALSE PREMISE, THEY
ABANDONED BY GIVING IT THEIR
HIGHEST DESIGNATION OF "WAR-ON,"
THE NEXT THING IS THEY BRING OUT
AN EXPERT TO SUPPORT IT, A
FOX-PERT IF YOU WILL.
ENTER THE SHERIFF FROM EARLIER.
>> I THINK IT'S COMPLETE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. YOU CAN GO TO
A HOME AT 2 OR 3 IN THE MORNING
THE KIDS ARE UP WEEK NIGHTS
SWATCHING SNACKS OUT OF BAGS ON
THE SOFAS WHILE THEIR PARENTS
ARE OUT ON THE STREETS.
>> Larry: PARENTS ON THE
STREET.
KIDS UP ALL NIGHT.
SNACK BAGS.
WHAT IS HE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
ARE YOU TELLING ME SLACKER
KIDS ARE KILLING COPS? I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED.
COULD YOU CLARIFY YOUR
CODED LANGUAGE.
>> YOU GOT A CERTAIN SEGMENT OF
SOCIETY THAT ARE VERY DEFIANT.
>> Larry: MM-MM.
CERTAIN SEGMENT. OK I'M A LITTLE
SUSPICIOUS
I TELL YOU I'LL GIVE YOU THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
WHEN YOU SAY A SEGMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE WAR ON COPS
I'M SURE YOU MEAN THE SOFA BAG
IN MURDER TOWN RIGHT.
>> THEY HATE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT HAS
PERPETUATED THE BALANCE WE SEE
HERE LATELY.
>> Larry: THERE IT IS. IN CASE
YOU MISSED
THE TRICK , THEY BLAMED  BLACK
LIVES ON MATTER FOR THE WAR OF
COPS THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
EXIST.
[LAUGHTER]
.
>> Larry: NOW, RIGHT.
THIS IS WHERE IT GETS GOOD.
NOW THAT FOX HAS ESTABLISHED
THAT THE FAKE WAR ON COPS IS THE
FAULT OF BLACK LIVES MATTER THAT
NOW IS A REALITY.
WE DON'T QUESTION IT. FOR THEIR
NEXT TECHNIQUE, THEY CHERRY PICK
MOMENTS FROM THE BLM MOVEMENT TO
HELP FOX PROVE THEIR EXPERTS'
FAKE THEORIIES. LUCKY FOR FOX,
BLACK LIVES MATTER, LIKE ANY
MOVEMENT, IS NOT PERFECT
>> CHANCE LIKE THIS FROM THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER MARCH THIS
MONTH IN MINNESOTA.
>> Larry: OKAY.
PIGS IN A BLANKET FRYIN' LIKE
BACON
THIS IS HORRIBLE.
NUMBER ONE YOU SHOULD NEVER
NEVER IMPLY ANY KIND OF VIOLENCE
SHOULD BE DONE TO COPS.
THEIR JOB IS HARD ENOUGH ALREADY
AND NUMBER TWO, PLEASE  DON'T
DRAG BACON INTO THIS, OKAY.
PLEASE.
[LAUGHTER]
BACON DIDN'T DO ANYTHING TO
ANYBODY EXCEPT BEING THE MOST
AWESOME THING ON EARTH, ALL
RIGHT.
NOW OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A SMALL
ISOLATED INCIDENT IN AN
OTHERWISE PEACEFUL
MOVEMENT. FOX, WHAT WAS YOUR
TAKE AWAY FROM THAT ONE MOMENT
THAT YOU KEEP PLAYING OVER
AND OVER AND OVER.
>> THEIR AGENDA IS IT'S OKAY TO
GO AHEAD AND KILL COPS.
PIGS IN A BLANKET FRY LIKE BACON
IS THAT UNCLEAR TO YOU.
THOSE ARE THEIR WORDS.
>> Larry: OKAY.
NOW ... I'M NOT A SPOKESPERSON
FOR BLACK LIVES MATTER BUT I'M
PRETTY SURE THEIR AGENDA IS JUST
TO GET POLICE TO STOP SHOOTING
UNARMED BLACK PEOPLE.
I MEAN THE FACT THAT WE EVEN
NEED THAT MOVEMENT IS INSANE.
THE FACT YOU'RE TRYING TO
PRESTO-CHANGE IT TO A WAR ON
COPS IS EVEN MORE INSANE. AND
ONCE THE MAGIC
TRICK IS DONE AND REALITY SEEMS
A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
RIGHT WING POLITICIANS CAN MAKE
POINTS LIKE THIS.
>> THE RHETORIC AND VILIFICATION
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OF THE POLICE
THAT'S COMING FROM THE TOP,
COMING FROM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU THIS IS
AN EXAMPLE OF THE LAWLESSNESS
OF THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
>> COULD YOU ELABORATE ON HOW
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS PLAYED A
ROLE IN THE MURDER OF POLICE
OFFICERS?
>> I THINK IT'S ABSENCE OF
LEADERSHIP.
>> Larry: OBAMA?
YOU'RE REALLY BLAMING THIS ON
OBAMA?
GET THE [BLEEP] REALLY?
I MEAN.
[CROWD CHEERING]
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
I MEAN I HAVE TO TELL YOU GUYS,
AS SOMEONE WHO LOVES THE ART OF
ILLUSION, I DESPISE FOX'S AGENDA
BUT I SO ADMIRE THEIR CRAFT